Can you hear me?
Is it?
Thank you.
Thank you very much all for coming to
our first debate in,
in the series a,
you will know that the title of the
debate is the world needs religion even
if it doesn't need God.
I don't know what the answer to that is,
but I think that one thing I do know is
that intelligence squared needs religion
for what has become an almost annual
ritual of debating about it.
Um,
many of you will have seen,
uh,
some of the those debates and the great
moments,
they've been the Catholic church as a
force for good atheisms a new
fundamentalism and stop bashing
Christians.
Um,
they've all been fantastic events and
this evenings is a,
um,
uh,
is going to add to that great lineage of
debates about religion.
Without any further ado,
let me introduce,
let me do one thing first.
Let me tell you about the voting.
You were all polled on the way in,
on your opinion about this.
At the,
I will announce the initial poll at the
end of the opening speeches,
and I will,
and you will then be pulled again during
the closing speeches that were,
the question will be,
how many minds have been changed by our
distinguished panel.